the Western frontispiece of amia
Cathedral has been something of a
problem in Gothic historiography and
authors have suggested that this is not
the frontispiece that was originally
intended that originally an extra bay
was intended with big square towers I
wanted to demonstrate though that these
rectangular towers were planned from the
start it is true that as we look at the
forms of the frontispiece there is
something of a disjunction between the
three simple gable portals that make up
the lower part of the design and the
much more ornate rather freely upper
levels made up of a middle triforium and
a king's gallery
coming beneath the rose window this can
be explained by the fact that the
Western Front of space was built fairly
rapidly right up to the balustrade above
the Rose probably finished within 20
years from the start of work between the
12 20s in the 12 40s only later however
towards the end of the 13th century did
the builders come back to finish the
upper frontispiece adding the triforium
and the Kings gallery the stylistic
forms up here are much much more ornate
and one developed the West Rose has
obviously failed because the present
tracery was installed at a date after
1500 and the caps of the towers above
the top of the Rose also belong to the
late Middle Ages from the side of the
facade we can see how very thin the
towers are in fact they're pretty much
double squares and from the flank of the
building we can see the windows of the
staircase turret ascending inside the
South West
Tower